got to want something kid then i wish i
had junk food from here in the sky
i am
that's it this is a new movie called
kazam i'm a genie
so you have three wishes on granite this
is a candy effect machine
it's all it's not real right can you oh
yeah
really if you're digging it i don't know
why there's tomato sauce in the
chocolate
french fries
a happy deal
i'm getting here with a lot of junk um i
have to ride my bikes and stuff
don't get all hysterical say thank you
for your miracle
the bike race where i'm trying to get
the kid to make nigga's first wish
and i started chasing around this round
i want you people know i did my own
stunts thank you
all of them all of them i guess my
favorite scene is the bike chase
cause he's the only 12-year-old that
doesn't know how to ride a bike in real
life
i do do not i i i learned i had to get a
bike tutor
i learned i did him this summer he had
to get a bike tutor i looked i lived in
the bronx
and you can't ride a bike in the rock
did you get took me away from you he had
a bike shot
someone with training wheels he had
training with him i did not have yeah
never had dreams yeah i play hoops
sometimes it's impossible why would you
want to play with me it just
depresses you for the
and i am working on my game for those
basketball people out there yeah you
guys will come back with some new stuff
next year
believe me that disturbed my seat
this is my boombox i'm gonna wrap in
genie with the attitude
cause i am the same man i'm more than i
see him you all are looking at your
dream
in your coffee on the bridge
but i consider myself a smooth rapper
and just uh the lowest level
of hardcoreness you know there's a like
i say there's
there's many levels of rap and to me
i like the music the music the beat the
drums
the melodies if i can get my head to go
up and down
and all my stress is released to me rap
music is a
stress reliever and here's a tip
this is the pointy shoes
[Music]
i had no idea who he was i really didn't
know
i thought it was like football or
something and then he explained to me
i was like who are you and i said my
friends know who you are
i said i don't watch basketball i don't
know the first day you know i never
thought that we were really going to be
as close as we are now i mean then the
second time i met him i knew like you
know
it's a friend for life the first day i
met you you stayed on the phone
you didn't even talk to me